the YouTube channel has really been
killing it since the november eighth
election of president elect Donald we've
had a number of days with a net increase
of over a thousand subscribers and I
can't thank all of our new subscribers
enough not only our new subscribers up
views are up the channel is on track to
actually have the best month ever in the
history of our YouTube channel in
November 2016 the immediate target is
300,000 subscribers and here's the thing
what a lot of people don't know about
YouTube is that most views come from
non-subscribers I think when I was most
recently looking at the data something
like seventy five percent of our views
are coming from nonsubscribers so as
important it is as it is to subscribe to
sort of say hey here's one vote saying I
like what your channel is doing and I
hope you'll do that by clicking the
subscribe button above below this video
it's really important to actually watch
videos and that that relates to
supporting the show in terms of ad
revenue assuming you don't have an ad
blocker and that those pre-roll ads are
actually playing and the other thing
that I actually do this myself so I can
make sure our videos are publishing
correctly you can turn on notifications
either to your smart phone or email
notifications for when we publish new
videos and I i I'm I would really love
it if you did that as well because we
want to have the most engaged subscriber
base possible I don't know exactly when
we are going to cross the 300,000
subscriber threshold uh I I certainly am
it's abundantly clear it's going to be
sooner than I thought before the
election because new subscribers have
just gone off the charts since the
november eighth election and clearly
people are hungry for different voices
people are increasingly realizing that
corporate media has failed and we're
right in there with you and you know
what if your approach from troll and you
just are coming by to either insult me
for being Jewish and leave insult in the
comments have at it you know we you are
not going to deter us from doing what it
is that we are going to do and what's so
funny I I was having this conversation
with Pat off the air I almost shouldn't
say this
but it doesn't even matter because that
the Trump trolls can't control
themselves a lot of our detractors pat
think that if they come by the youtube
channel and dislike a video or leave a
comment but it's a negative comment that
it somehow is bad the YouTube algorithm
sees all engagement as a good thing and
when you have a video that has a lot of
comments and both likes and dislikes
that only helps us in the YouTube
algorithm and I I know some people will
say David you shouldn't tell the trolls
that but I've been saying it off and on
for years they don't care they're going
to keep doing it and helping us by the
way yeah I thought you were gonna leave
that part out but I love that how the
wording of the trolls can't control
themselves ya know they can I mean it's
like I can I tell the trolls if you
really want to hurt our channel you
should not be down voting you should not
be commenting and you certainly
shouldn't be watching but they can't
help themselves so I I'm comfortable
saying this and they they continue to be
part of the community for better or
worse they are part of the community
that exists on youtube and you know what
they're going to be part of the reason
why we get to those 300,000 subscribers
eventually